el acuerdo firmado por Estados Unidos el
Reino Unido y Australia miembros de laus
es un típico producto de la mentalidad
de la Guerra Fría lo ha dicho hoy el
Ministerio de exteriores chino que ha
acusado los tres de menospreciar las
inquietudes de la comunidad
internacional y de caminar por la senda
del peligro y el error ya un día antes
el representante chino en la ONU había
alertado que este acuerdo va a estimular
la carrera armamentista en la zona y
había subrayado la ironía de que dos
países que se declaran contrarios a la
proliferación nuclear le estén
transfiriendo tecnología nuclear a otro
que no la tiene en el centro del debate
están los submarinos que la organización
militar va a proporcionar Australia ese
acuerdo no solo enfadado a China otros
países de la zona como Malasia o
Indonesia también lo han criticado los
expertos por su parte alertan de que
otros países podrían utilizar la vía
australiana el aucus fue que fue creado
dos años atrás con la declarada
intención de frenar a china en el
Pacífico Estados Unidos le discute la
primacía global a China al Reino Unido
buscaba zonas de influencia después del
brexit y Australia en aquellos momentos
coleccionaba roces diarios con China la
subida al poder de los laboristas rebajó
las tensiones pero es bastante probable
que los submarinos las devuelvan con
toda su intensidad